okay and I'm asking you a trivia
question bring it Patrick mahomes threw
for 278 yards in the second quarter
yesterday that's the second most yards
in a single quarter in NFL history who
holds the record for the most gosh a
tough one this is a tough one and I feel
like I heard someone say this on TV last
night I don't know yet how about came to
my head no it's alright I'll just go I'm
just gonna throw a random day I'm gonna
go with Brett Favre no it's drew Brees
ah when in doubt when the question is
about a quarterback throwing for a lot
of yards Drew Brees is the guy you go to
anytime we have an accord he had 294
yards in a quarter in 2008 94 I mean 278
and then I thought it was like the most
touchdown passes in a quarter in a long
long time - as far as you know he threw
four in the second quarter but I can't
remember who the hell that was either it
was too late watched too many damn game
alright I got the first pick and the
biggest statement of the day by far Bill
Belichick
yeah you know I don't want to pick one
member of the New England Patriots and
say this person this person this person
oh just it's Bella check yes look he's
determined this year they're not gonna
go three and five on the road yeah they
they want to be wire-to-wire great so
that they can beat the Chiefs I think
that close call against Kansas City in
the AFC Championship game scared them
yeah and you go back and you draw the
lines look at what we did last year to
put us in this position where we had to
go to Arrowhead Stadium for that game
three and five at home that's why they
had to go to Arrowhead Stadium they're
not going back there because the next
time they go back they ain't getting out
with the Lamar Hunt trophy so this is
domination this is a different kind of
Patriots vibe in September than we're
used to seeing and now look the quality
of the opponent especially yesterday
still it doesn't matter team they've not
been relegated to the CFL yet right they
very well may be 43 nothing yesterday 33
to 3 on the night they raised the banner
and the Patriots keep going to get the
Jets next week they got the bills the
week after that they get an opportunity
to deliver an early final nail in the a
see east coffin but their prize is
number one seed without question and who
knows maybe it will be 2007 all over
again when is it too early to talk about
the team going undefeated well when
you're 76 to 3 to start the season it's
not too early no I mean it's the New
England Patriots we're allowed to talk
about crazy stuff with them because it's
not that crazy when you talk about the
New England Patriots I mean they're
gonna play the Jets X we can win they're
gonna have a tough time in Buffalo I'll
say that's like a that'll be a tough
definitely a tough one I'm not gonna
give them the win they're all the way
but then it's the Redskins the Giants
and the Jets again I mean they're
they're easily gonna be like 6 & 1 maybe
7 and oh into that week 8 matchup
against the Cleveland Browns so you
gotta be careful and Bubba I want to
spread things they may throw on either
way we already farther that was an
amazing statement you picked my pick
will be the Cowboys offense I mean the
second week in a row to where you know
last week okay was it week one is it the
Giants you know yet all offseason to
game plan but here we go week two and
again I know the Redskins are not like a
special defense and don't have a special
secondary or anything like that but the
Cowboys going up to Washington playing
there have usually been a little
stagnant offensively over the last few
years when you look at those matchups
and you know the Redskins were desperate
after being all 1-1 their home opener
they're trying to get off the schnide
and win a football game but the Cowboys
offense had answers for everything a
little bit of a slow start but then dak
Prescott started dealing the run game
showed a lot of life yesterday Zeke
Elliott ran for what was at 111 yards on
23 carries so the Dallas Cowboys I just
can't give enough credit to Jason
Garrett telling more and of course the
man driving the ship and dak Prescott
and the way he looks the decisions
everything it's been phenomenal yeah I I
really thought that that they would step
into a bear trap against Washington his
Washington looked good early on against
Philly I thought with Adrian Peterson
back on the field there'd be a level of
anger
but ultimately they just doesn't have
the horses right how boys do they have a
great team on both sides yes I do we
were trying to figure out their
weaknesses I don't know what weakness
they have it though I don't either all
right I am going to go with your San
Francisco 49 and what I know I just
you're stealing all my damn not stealing
it's obvious it's hanging out there
you're you could have taken Kyle
Shanahan and your 49ers yeah you're
right okay but look 41 to 17 and the
offense is working the running game is
working the passing game is working like
you said yesterday the he cracked the
code yeah I'm writing the code and and
and Jimmy Garoppolo is only gonna get
better that's what Kyle told me after
the game that he still has a way to go
to be as good as he's capable of being
because he's still less than a year
removed from that torn ACL that he
suffered week three a season ago at
Arrowhead Stadium and now I remember we
were talking before the season that's
kind of a weird start to the year for
the 49ers they play in Tampa they play
in Cincinnati and then they have a home
open it gets the Steelers not the
Steelers are owing to their to a no and
I asked how about the weekend Youngstown
yeah I said when he was coaching on the
East Coast he never believed that that
there was an issue with travel and it's
always better to be home and be with
your family being your routine once he
ended up coaching a West Coast team he
realized my god it really is difficult
to fly to the East Coast play a game
yeah come back get readjusted and then
fly again and he said Wednesday or
Thursday his guys were really kind of
dead that was when it really hit them
yeah but by Sunday were bouncing off the
walls and they were good to go and they
come back again with a couple of games
between the Saints and the Bears I
believe later in the year and I think
they're gonna stay in Youngstown again
yeah it works it's great job by Kyle
Shanahan I mean there's nothing there's
nothing more you can say about that and
you know to your point to I mean their
offense was phenomenal yesterday when
Kyle Shanahan cracks the code it's one
of the prettiest things you can see as
far as offensive football is concerned I
mean you know like I joked about even on
Sunday Night Football last night and you
earlier in the show some of those passes
guys are so wide open I mean anybody Joe
Schmo walking down the street could have
completed a bunch of those four
touchdowns and that's not to take
anything away from Jimmy Garoppolo but
just a great job by Shanahan and it is
scary to your point that you
I don't think Jimmy Garoppolo is best
yet so when you can win two football
games and then have an alpha offensive
output of almost six hundred yards and
would they run for 259 yards on the
ground what was their average per 1000 I
don't know let's see like over six yards
of carry out Lee who it was it was 8.4
8.4 per offensive play in general which
is insane but yeah phenomenal job there
that certainly was a statement so I'm
with you there now I gotta find my
statement you stole my pic there and I'm
just not sure which one I want to go
usually in a three round draft with two
people it's advisable to have six red I
have six I've been doing this for a
little I just don't know which one I
want to go with okay I think if I'm
gonna you know what I'm gonna go a
little off the radar here a little the
Chiefs defense okay they kind of get
slept down a little bit but the Chiefs
defense is an improved unit and lat
yesterday against the Oakland Raiders
okay got off to a kind of a shaky start
you win oh gosh here we go the Chiefs
defense they stink
you know mahomes is gonna have to throw
lasers all over the field they're gonna
have to score 40-something points to win
a football game but settled in nicely
and the Chiefs defense for the first
time in a long time has a secondary you
can rely on a little bit you know with
the with fuller and brashaad Breeland
being there and the honey badger you
know they're just not a pushover anymore
with Steve Spagnola is defense I think
they made the right adjustments to the
roster but you know to give up 10 early
points in the first quarter and then
pitch a shutout from that's that point
on got to give them a lot of credit I
mean they do look like an improved unit
altogether we knew the offense was gonna
be great but the offense wasn't just
dominant yesterday as we saw they had a
quarter of dominance and then the rest
of it was the defense holding on to a
lead and I got to give them a lot of
credit there because it were nobodies
giving an attention I wanted to that was
good that was good but you you ignored
one of your other friends I can't
believe you're gonna leave Josh Allen a
buffalo bill he was the one I was
tossing 28 to 14 win at MetLife Stadium
they'll complete the sweep of MetLife
Stadium to start the season and they had
to stretch of 38 to 7 between the two
games they were down 16 nothing to the
Jets between what they did to come back
and win that game and how they got off
to a 21-7 start yeah 38 to 7
and and just just dominance and we'll
see what they do against better
opposition because you know those early
season opponents you never know how bad
they are or how good they are and for
the Jets and Bill's chances are they're
gonna be closer or the Jets and Giants
are either closer to the bottom end of
the NFL than the top end but we'll see
in the jar that's just the Giants just
let me just say this yeah say it why not
just put in Daniel Jones now yeah
Eli until they're out of contention why
not give the kid a chance to play in
some games that count III don't know
either now and maybe the reaction from
the fans yesterday and the the way the
offense looked in general maybe that'll
give the Mehra's and the Giants
organization a little confidence to pull
the cord there if need be remember how
mad John Mara got when it was suggested
that he's holding on to Eli Manning out
of sentiment town yeah that's right yeah
methinks thou doth protest too much John
Mara
that's why you lie Manning still the
quarterback he delivered those two Super
Bowl championships they got they got
scared by the reaction a couple of years
ago when they tried to bench him and I
think it's sentimentality that has Eli
Manning in that job any other
quarterback any other team any other
time he benched by now would be gone by
now on the bench but would be gone yeah
I agree I do I agree and it wasn't it
wasn't pretty yesterday and I don't want
to sit here and just bag on Eli it's not
all his fault they don't have great
weapons around them and once he stops
yeah I know and then you know Sterling
Shepard was hurt yesterday they had
another other a bunch of injuries at the
receiver position but certainly doesn't
look good and I understand that all
right I mean I want to go with the Rams
but the fact that Drew Brees got hurt
you know
the Rams I just giving them a
consolation prize I'm gonna give the
Seattle Seahawks a little love that's
good you like it you know except that I
mean not a not a real pretty week one
win got caught off guard by a team that
I think they just thought uh Cincinnati
will beat them but then the travel to
the East Coast time zone play that
dreaded 1:00 o'clock game just like you
were talking about with the San
Francisco 49ers and yet we don't even
talk about them at times and Russell
Wilson just is an absolute baller and
it's and it's it's a baller with you
know it's different and maybe compared
to other quarterbacks who had big days
yesterday because he
a lot of it it's just Russell Wilson
making phenomenal throws it's not like
oh wow what great play design on the
offensive side of the ball and there's a
20 yard completion over the middle
without a guy in the picture on the TV
screen no there's always somebody in the
screen when Russell Wilson thrown the
ball and usually it's tight coverage and
he just makes it happen but the Seahawks
Pete Carroll how can I not give them
credit here they are to a know again
they're always competing or they never
lay eggs they're in every football game
it doesn't matter if you're the big bad
Steelers at home whatever it may be they
made a statement and there they're gonna
be here all year long yeah I agree with
you completely and three teams in the
NFC West are two-and-oh crazy 49ers
Seahawks and I have some good games
coming up in that division when those
two teams when those three teams start
playing each other twice per year
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports